foreign
there was an article in Forbes
um that I saw and I was talking about
before paying off all your debt consider
the downsides
the downsides of paying all of your debt
off so before I even read this I have to
say so in in my nerd World whenever
there's a study cited like a scientific
study the authors have to put their
conflicts of interest down there whose
funds their lab who where they receive
money from yeah just in case they're
writing a um a a research paper on how
good sugar is for you and they're
sponsored by like sugar like gummy bears
of America right and so they have to
they have to disclose that anytime I see
something like this I always have to
wonder like
who's who's whose author is behind this
because it's just just on its merits
it's silly but go ahead totally no
that's a great Point that's a good point
okay so uh the article goes on that the
author is saying that they paid off uh
three hundred thousand dollars of debt
in their 30s which they're doing the
fire movement so the whole retire early
kind of movement so they basically lived
on nothing and put all their money to
pay off debt and to retire
so here are some of the downsides John
and some of these honestly I'm like yeah
this some of these make sense uh you may
have hiccups traveling internationally
so she gave up credit cards several
years ago uh and she said I saw a lot of
difference in my spending habits I
became a lot more intentional and spent
significantly less money overall by
getting rid of the cards and using a
debit card
and she said but some of the hotels
required a credit card for incidentals
and we had to negotiate using our debit
card one particular car rental business
in Italy required cards to have credit
limits that would cover up to the
insurance limit and our debit card did
not do that okay so but I want to stop
here this whole paragraph is all
positive if you ask me there's some
inconvenience
but it's not a downside it's not a
downside right so I gave up using credit
cards and I started being more
intentional in spending less ta-da
that's what we tell people all the time
totally um I stopped taking uh cash out
all right I mean it's like it's we
started tracking cash to stick to our
budget Tada a few hotels a few
we had to have an extra conversation
okay right I you and I travel a lot we
both have to do that yes I'm traveling
internationally in a few weeks
um I had to my the person who's putting
together the travel for me I had my
debit card there to split the purchase
twice because there was a limit on that
debit card and we contacted the bank but
he had to run it twice and split it it
was a pain in the butt and but it was it
was an extra phone call for two minutes
for two minutes yep that's it and the
rental car yep one particular rental car
company wouldn't rent and and I run into
that traveling so you find the rental
car companies that will and we have two
of those when it's not used we kind of
switch off yep and I literally use those
I looked at one in the Dallas airport
and I said please help me give you my
money and they were like well it's 24
hours I said no listen I'm trying to
give you my money they didn't want my
business that's great and I literally
went to the next counter and I said will
you help me and they're like oh my gosh
they made a car in four minutes that's
right that's right okay the next one is
your credit score may have disappeared
uh even with an extensive credit history
so in 2015
millions of American consumers
representing about 11 of all adults were
credit and visible meaning they didn't
have a credit score so she goes through
talking about that yeah if you don't
have a credit score you can run into
some issues
um just like taking out a mortgage which
is her next points but this is kind of
like saying um I don't want to get
married because I used to date a lot and
I was really good at dating and I don't
want to lose my reputation as a great
day right it's like when you get married
you're like that's not your identity
anymore and so when you're married to
credit scores yep as you're as the
metric for whether I'm financially
successful or not and the one that blew
my mind I say this all the time on the
show if I called the author of this
article and just gave her a million
dollars in cash it would not change her
credit score because it has nothing to
do with your wealth with how much money
you have nothing it has to do with how
much you can borrow how much based on
how much you've borrowed in the past and
how do you paying it back has nothing to
do with your financial situation that's
right so and the credit score will go
down you guys if you get out of debt
just like she experienced your credit
score I think it's on average 12 to 18
months it basically just goes down down
down down down and disappears so if
you're going to get a mortgage which
we'll talk about that next because
that's her next point then yeah if you
pull your credit score for any reason
it's not going to be great as you're
getting out of debt but eventually it
will become undetermined meaning that
you just they can't determine a credit
score because you don't have credit
history and here's what it says for a
while I just lived without a credit
score paying for everything in cash and
not having any issues because my house
was paid off and I wasn't intending to
move
that's the thing and then look and then
covet came and I needed to make some
drastic changes awesome happened to
millions and millions of people and they
need to get a new home and sell the one
I paid off and that leads us to the next
Point yep so her next point of uh that a
downside of paying off all your debt is
that if it's harder to take out a loan
particularly a mortgage so we talk about
this a lot on the show we don't want you
to have any debt so you shouldn't be
applying for any kind of loan and not a
personal loan not a car loan no loan so
there's no reason to pull the credit
score for a loan now a mortgage is the
one type of debts we always say we won't
yell at you for but you can still get a
mortgage through manual underwriting
okay so this is where instead of pulling
a credit score and deciding dependent
upon the score can you get the loan or
not they actually look at you the person
and you have to be current on a job for
two years and current on all of your
bills I like to say for at least two
years so keep a record of your cell
phone payments uh cable internet
electricity like any type of bills that
you have monthly keep track of those if
you know in the future hey we're not
gonna have a credit score and we're
going to want to buy a home they're
going to need which all those are kept
with your online profile of those
individual things right they keep on
let's look at ours and we still get
paper well that's because you'll you'll
hate the environment it's fine it's
Junior Winston it's fun why do we still
do we do we still get paper we make our
own butter so there we go it's
2023. it's online so you can go back and
look at all your history online but yeah
getting a mortgage Yes again
inconvenient and we will we'll admit to
that all day long well I think George
said it was an extra an extra piece of
paper like it was an extra sheet he had
to fill out for him yeah I think so yeah
yeah and here's again I always want to
look at these titles and then read the
actual article this is scientific
articles this is headlines because
before paying off all your debt consider
the downsides ultimately this section
the hardest thing right is about getting
a loan for a mortgage that's fair
it was really frustrating to explain my
situation that is not a downside America
that is simply a momentary inconvenience
and kind of a pain in the butt when all
these uh tv ads have you able to get a
mortgage on your cell phone you actually
had to tell the banker I need to do
manual unwrite underwriting because I'm
a millionaire I just don't owe anybody
any money I'd like to make a purchase
and they'll all go okay like send your
cell phone bill right I mean if if the
maximum downside in your life
is it you're really frustrated
explaining your situation you're doing
all right you're doing good you're doing
great that's a good answer good job
America all right and the last one this
is my favorite one oh geez ready you may
you may feel guilt spending money even
when you can afford it so
[Laughter]
what a downside being debt free not
paying interest not owing anyone
anything having the freedom to make your
own decisions but man I feel guilty
every now and then about spending money
so I'm not laughing at the guilt I feel
this I came from a home that was highly
money insecure it was a time it was
tough I still to this day
have to Exhale I walked around Guitar
Center the other night budgeted in hand
like ready to rock and roll and I
couldn't do it I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it until finally I did it
right it was tough I had that guilt is
real that is not a downside to paying
off my debt that is a built-in
trauma response that I have that me and
a counselor need to work out I don't
need to counsel people and and tell them
hey
don't don't get peace in your life
because you're going to feel weird about
it I need to go deal with my personal
feelings and so if this is you if you've
paid off everything and you realize it
didn't solve all your childhood wounds
it won't yep you gotta go do that work
such a good point and a lot of people
feel this you guys like that is
something we run into so if you're on
baby steps four and Beyond like force
yourself to spend and enjoy build that
muscle the practice there you go yeah in
practice